hmm use season 4 part 2 is now out and
after our last video you decided to come
back what are you telling me you could
have just moved on picked another
subscribe to someone else but you came
back to me what are you saying what do
you want I want Giza it's me your dark
side here to spoil the show so you've
just finished you season four part two
and man do we have a lot to talk about
throughout this video we're gonna be
recapping the new Netflix show and also
discussing the ending and where it could
be going I just want to get straight
into it but full spoilers ahead so if
you haven't checked it out then check
out now without the way huge thank you
for clicking this now let's get into you
season four
okay so after all the breadcrumbs were
laid in part one part two has us finally
meeting Kate's Father Tom Lockwood
played by Greg Kinnear he's a devious
evil man who's as obsessed with Kate as
Joe is it's a fatherly Obsession but we
learn that he secretly controlled every
aspect of her life every job she got
every charitable event that she set up
it was all him controlling things from
the Shadows we discover that he's
learned who Joel is early on and that he
wants him to use a certain set of skills
to take out Rhys Montrose Joe ends up
doing this which is when we get our
first major twist now it turns out that
Geo actually imagined this killer
version of Rhys and he represents his
darker and more evil side as we watch
the show even though we've seen him
doing horrendous things audiences have
still grown to like Joe because we see
things from his point of view he is very
much presented his killer with a heart
of gold to US Raz Reese represents what
he's really like this plays in the
ending with him very much embracing this
side after Kate enables him to do what
he wants now I think that the twist is
very much gonna make or break the show
for a lot of people and I do roll my
eyes a lot when twists like this are
revealed it was shocking back in 1999
when it was used as Potter Fight Club
but since then we've had countless shows
in films using this as a narrative
device I saw this theory in the wake of
part one and just thought it was pretty
stupid but hey you got it right so who
looks stupid now me again anyway as I
saw this sliding into place I thought no
way are they doing this stupid twist and
I was ready to turn it off when the
secondary stepped out however I kept
watching and adding that in all fairness
they do do a lot with the reveal it
allows us to see Joe for who he really
is and to me the good guy is actually
the facade I think it shows how good
that pen Bachelor is when he can be an
evil murderous stalker and still have
people running for him now the reason he
created this idea of Rhys is because he
became obsessed with him after moving to
England Rhys very much represents
everything Joe wants to be and in many
ways his Arc mirrors the tale at the
real tells us about himself he came from
nothing and by the end of the season
he's plucked out of it by a rich
figurehead much like how Rhys was he too
grew up poor but then learned he was the
son of a Duke which allowed him to go
into the upper class that's very much
what happens with jar at the end of the
season which we'll talk more about later
on in the video now it's also important
to bear in mind that Lockwood fits his
mold too he came from nothing and has
used murder to get his own way Joe
believes that he's like Rhys when in
reality he's like Tom and if his son
Henry comes back into the show then he
may end up treating him like how Tom
treated Kate a Joe's obsession with Rhys
is very much the extreme of a parasocial
relationship in case you don't know this
typically revolves around someone who
believes that they have a friendship
with a celebrity or a figurehead we see
this demonstrating Phoebe stalker with
her believing that Sheen phoebs are
actually friends I've actually had
something similar happen but no not with
you mate because me and you were
actually really good mates because of
that time you hit the thumbs up button
on video and there's some nice moments
that kind of tie back to things from
earlier in the season and there's a
video that Joe watches in which Rhys
talks about the rich this is word for
word what he says to Tom in the club in
episode one and it shows how he
projected him into his real life anyway
the reveal with Reese allows us to see a
lot of things from a new angle such as
what really happened with Marianne we
learned that he didn't let her go and
that he in fact kidnapped her and locked
her in a cage classic Joe's style
episode 7 actually has a really good bit
of foreshadowing towards this when we
see Kate say what even is that like a
condemned bomb shelter okay
time fine we like to find out that this
is where Marianne's being kept and Joe
was subconsciously going on this walk
with her to check it out even if he
didn't know why he's so desperate to
find out where she is so that he can
free her but Rhys won't reveal the truth
to him now whilst this is going on Nadia
starts looking into her unassuming
lecturer a better twist would be a
mild-mannered average Joe Average Joe oh
I get it so yeah she suspects something
is up with him and after finding a key
she discovers Marianne trapped in a cage
they start to put together a plan whilst
Joe fights his doc aside tries to keep
things going with Kate and also deals
with her father it was good to see the
cage back as it's become a staple of you
whereas people in the past have fallen
victim to it I love watching Mariana
Nadia's plan working out in the end they
realize that if the entire thing's
expose that Joe will just go on a hiding
and we've of course seen this happen
over and over again throughout the show
now Nadia goes to Marianne once more and
he switches the number in her phone to
make it seem like her daughter is being
taken away from her whilst all this is
going on we have lady Phoebe's wedding
going down but she has a psychotic break
after realizing exactly how things will
turn out her husband is killed by Tom
and he also tries to get his daughter to
take over the throne it's revealed that
Kate was actually behind the event that
gave all those kids cancer and he's
purposely made the choice to step away
from this life now after Marianne
collapses Joe puts himself on trial with
his victims and we get cameos from back
in love Beck is an important victim to
focus on as Joe of course killed her in
New York which is where he ends up
returning to in the end love also gives
him a gun and says that someone needs to
die in order for this to end which is a
path that he almost ends up taking now
this is foreshadowed at the start of
episode 10 and it's possible that it's
also giving us clues about where things
will end up going with Joe intobias
Wolf's story Bullet in the Brain the
hero is going to die he wakes up the
next day and goes to Marianne to find
her apparently dead which puts in the
place and next part of her Nadia's plan
he dumps her body and whilst all this is
going on K finds out the truth about her
real life she tells Joe about all the
files her dad kept on her and Joe knows
that he has to get rid of him next she
ends up killing Tom and pinning it on
his bodyguard it seems like Kate's
finally free of her father and then goes
to jump over a bridge which seemingly
kills the wreath side of him again very
similar to fight club and how Tyler
didn't was killed in that spoiler alert
Rhys tells him that he loves him and Joe
thanks him before throwing him over the
bridge and jumping in himself upon
hitting the water though he's
immediately filled with regret and we
discover that he was rescued by a patrol
boat he awakens in hospital and as this
is going on we get the reveal of Nadia
and Marianne's plan Marianne pretended
to be devastated at losing her daughter
and she took enough pills to make it
seem like she was dead Nadia then woke
her up once Joe dumped her body and
being assumed dead means that she can
Now operate under the radar Joe is an
obsessive who can't let things go unless
she has to take this step to stop him
coming after her and her daughter now
back at the hospital kale arrives and
confirms that Tom was setting up Joe due
to some DNA found on the real Reese's
body however because of his death She's
now gained all of his power and
resources and he's covered for Joe and
made it so he'll never be tied to the
murder she makes a deal with Giada they
keep each other good and this is
seemingly an opposite to love rise those
two enabled each other they promised to
keep themselves on the right track which
means that Kate won't turn into a father
and Joe won't turn into Rhys both face a
Monumental task ahead of them and Kate's
worried that she'll be corrupted by the
business side of things and go back to
making choices that end up costing lives
Gia admits his past to her along with
his real name and he tells her
everything will probably not everything
because some of it's pretty bad now most
people that they would run for the hell
but they've made this promise Angie of
course has dealt with ruthless men
before although it seems like Joe has
turned the corner we get it revealed in
the Nadia scene said he's still the same
old Joe you know it was it was cracking
me up to hear him revealing his
diabolical plans to Taylor Swift's
anti-heroes and the lyrics in that of
course have her admitting she's the
problem much like how Joe does it also
has a line about how it's exhausting
rooting for the anti-hero which very
much sums us up rooting for Joe now we
hear that the rich social crowd are
still as toxic as ever except for Phoebe
who now teaches English in Thailand
Marianne is back with her daughter and
ethelene that Joe is now getting
positive publicity she starts to put
things in place to potentially get him
back from here we cut to New York and
see that Joe has returned home to Where
it All Began he's even bought a Bookshop
and no we don't know which one this is I
I don't think it'll surprise anyone if
it's revealed it's the one from season
one all the blame is put on love and any
tough questions are shut down by PR
however Joe is clearly not ready to
change and we discover that he actually
killed Nadia's boyfriend and pinned
Reese's death on him he gives her a
reason for his death and says that she
killed him after discovering it now Mima
May Mo went back and forth over what
actually happened with this as it's kind
of unclear what ends up going on with
the Eat the Rich killer Mo took it as
those crimes being pinned on Nadia which
is why she went to jail I kind of saw it
as being pinned on Eddie and then Nadia
found this and killed him but here's
what Joe says verbatim to kind of
explain what happens
now there's gonna be a box found in your
bedroom by the police Reese montrose's
things Anonymous tipster they'll realize
it was Eddie that's why you killed him
you have so many gifts I'm looking
forward to watching what you do next hmm
so yeah that's kind of how I read it but
look I'm a mate like an utter
so make sure you leave a comment
below on whether you agree with me or
whether you agree with Mo don't tell him
though if you agree with me because
it'll break his heart hearing so many
people side with me over him either way
in prison Nadia's kept her mouth closed
and overlooking New York Joan Kate have
vowed to change the world killing is
much easier now and Joe says that he's
now honest about it rather than trying
to sell us the lie that he's the good
guy he's finally embracing his dark side
and he'll do whatever he can to make
sure he and Kate stay on top now going
into the future there's not much we can
go off if we look at the source material
the third book centers around Joe moving
to the Midwest which is where he
obsesses over a woman called Mary Kay
DeMarco the sequel to this will be
released this year but the storyline in
the prior books such a far departure
from the show that I can't really see
them lining up I also think that the
ending of the season coming full circle
should also yeah I know the third book
in season four look it gets confusing
but the the second book was like season
two and season three but you get what
I'm saying now I also think the ending
of the season coming full circle shows
that they are pretty much ready to wrap
things up with season five Netflix are
killers when it comes to canceling shows
so I'm hoping that we get it but I can
see things ending back where it all
started a Joe actually has several
people out to get him at this point
Beyond just Marianne though I do think
she will come into it I can also see
Nadia being brought back along with
Ellie Jenner Ortega is so hot right now
and she was actually supposed to appear
in season four however she was making
Wednesday whilst it was being filmed and
therefore she couldn't feature in it I
really hope they work things out
prophecies in five and get her back and
we could get three women who know the
truth about Joe attempting to bring down
his Empire all are aware of what he's
really like and it would give the fifth
season some people where desperate to
see drop him I hope this happens too and
I think that jump racing is dark side is
probably the final progression of his
character with nothing holding him back
he's truly gonna appear to the audience
as the monster he was all along now he
has the power and resources to cover up
any crime he commits and Kate has very
much ended up with her father he has
reneged on their deal and unfortunately
I can also see that happening with K2
both promised to keep each other good
but with Joe not sticking to that I
doubt he'll be able to Keep Her On Track
either I'd love it if season 5 was a
full-on villain story with Marianne
Ellie and Nadia on the other side trying
to take them down I think that would be
the perfect way to take things it would
bring in a lot from the prior Seasons
whilst also giving us characters that we
can root for against Joe now we actually
had our mates over at this streamer.com
do an interview with showrunner Sarah
gamble on the series and most sent me
over some of the answers in advance so I
could talk about them in this video
lovely lad and here's what Sarah had to
say when it came to what characters
she'd like to bring back there's so many
I'd like to bring back and by the way a
bunch of dead ones there are some
survivors at the end of this season that
I think certainly have reason to show
their face again I think I've mentioned
this before and Jenna has mentioned it
as well that we had an idea to bring
Ellie back and then we heard she got
cast in some other little show I know
Jenna is very very busy so if we're
lucky to get a tiny sliver of her time
maybe we can go back and tell that
Ellie's story so yeah maybe Ellie won't
be integrated as much as I'd hope but we
could still get an Amanda Waller type
thing and see her on Skype calls all the
time now she also said that New York was
gonna be a victory march home and though
she didn't confirm whether Reese would
be back she said Ed knocked it out the
park and they're trying to integrate him
further so lots of things to look
forward to as we get into season five
and those are kind of my hopes for what
happens next now as for my thoughts on
this entry I do feel like you is kind of
sticking to the formula a bit too much
and I'd love to see Joe at least face
some consequences at some point again
the twist fell flat for me on its reveal
but as they worked it out in the season
I think it did come across really well
and watching Ed speelas just Hamming it
up makes a great addition to the show I
like him as much as I like Joel and
seeing him being the devil on Joe's
shoulder works really well for the
Dynamics so yeah another pretty solid
season but I am ready to see things wrap
up next time hopefully we get that fifth
entry but but to be honest you never
know with Netflix anyway overall I'm
scoring it a 7 out of 10 and obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
show below we are in competition right
now giving away the Rocky 4 box set to
three subscribers on the 15th of March
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
leave a comment below with your thoughts
on the season we pick the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are unscreen right now save
that to you then message me on Twitter
at heavy spoilers you want someone else
to watch make sure you check out one of
our breakdowns on screen right now which
is gonna be another fun thing that you
can use to kill sometime you you get
over there right now or I'm kicking off
and I'll see you over there and I'm
still stalking you I'm behind you gotta
get you
foreign